Let's go next to our caller from the two eight
one area code.
Who's calling today from two eight one
Hey David, this is Jared from Houston.
Hey Jared, what's going on?
So I'm a first time caller and I voted for
Bernie in 2016 in the primary.
Okay.
And one of the reasons why I'm moving off
of him, because I've been thinking not necessarily
about his electability, but what he could
actually do if he got elected.
So let's, like, let's, let's take the best
case scenario.
He gets a house and Senate that's democratic.
Yep.
We know like a lot of Dems oppose Medicare
for all.
And you already mentioned the campaign finance
reform.
Yeah.
And what I'm worried about.
He gets elected, he gets pushed back by moderate
Democrats, progresses, get depressed, and
then the Republicans will sweep back in 22
because the Democrats are in fighting so much.
And I just wanted to know, do you think if
he were to get elected, could he kind of keep
that democratic?
Would they want to send it?
Could he keep it even United?
So let's take it, let's make it less hypothetical
because even in your hypothesis, there's already
things you're mentioning that aren't going
to happen.
So let me give you an example.
The Senate is not going democratic in 2020
unless I am incredibly missing something.
So the idea that in his first two years Bernie
will have the house and Senate not going to
happen.
Now as far as 2022 typically
a new president
has their first midterm not go their way.
Everything is kind of different right now.
And the 2022 Senate map actually favors Democrats.
So let's take the conversation in a slightly
different direction, which is you are given
that you are right, that for example, not
every Democrat is on board with Medicare for
all anyway.
What is the benefit of having a president
who wants Medicare for all versus a president
like Joe Biden who wants to like tweak Obamacare
and add a public option?
And the answer is you often end up, unfortunately
this is sort of how it works.
You often end up in a sort of middle of the
road position between what the party in power
wants in the middle of what the party in power
wants.
So what I can tell you is the following.
If Bernie is the president and Democrats have
the Senate and Democrats have the house,
it's,
I feel very plausible that we don't get Medicare
for all, but whatever we end up negotiating
too is going to be way better than what we
will get if Joe Biden is president.
Right.
So that's my approach and everything you're
saying is correct, but we're still way better
off.
Yeah, that makes sense.
I think it's just like, I just think about
the whole no middle ground.
I'm kind of concerned that a lot of Bernie
supporters would not even accept that.
Even the fee where the move, if he moves anywhere,
right.
Well it's not going to be up to them ultimately.
Right.
I mean we vote to elect the president.
Trump did a whole bunch of stuff.
He didn't tell his supporters he was going
to do at a certain point it's like listen,
they might not like it, but ultimately Bernie
is going to get whoever is president will
get whatever is closest to what they want
that they can get at the time.
And that's kind of the way politics works.
Okay.
Thank you.
Alright, uh, great to hear from you.
I appreciate the phone call.
Let's take a quick break.
If you are holding, don't hang up.
Don't hang up with your holding because we
will go right back to the phones after this.